some believe that its name is due to a
seasonal cyanobacterium tresum arrium
which sometimes gives it a certain
reddish Hue others however believe that
its origin is much more epic and
dramatic that it has to do with all the
Egyptians who died when Moses saved the
Israelites separating the Waters of this
evil with the help of God be that as it
may the Red Sea is redder than ever
today and not exactly because of its
name or its color take a look
Red Sea attacks pose another threat to
global economy Red Sea chaos risks
driving up price of goods for global
economy attacks on shipping in the Red
Sea are a blow to global trade in 2023
around 24,000 vessels have plied the
passage accounting for some 10% of
global Seaborn trade by volume that
includes 20% of the world's container
traffic nearly 10% of Seaborn oil and 8%
of liquefied natural gas visual politic
community the houthi forces have decided
to attack ships passing through the area
in protest against Israel's offensive on
Gaza the hudies are one of the two sides
that have been fighting Yemen's Civil
War for years we're talking about what
is also considered the yemeni arm of
Iran in this case we are not talking
about a small terrorist group but a
reasonably organized fighting force with
years of combat experience take for
example this video that the group
published as you can see we are not
talking about about improvised Rockets
or assaults in underprepared boats but
about real amphibious operations it
stands to reason that this poses a
serious danger for the commercial ships
that cross the sewers canal in One
Direction or another in other words one
of the most important shipping lanes in
the world is now under
threat
some companies are already announcing
that they will stop transiting these
waters for the time being world's
largest shipping firm Mees suspends Red
Sea traffic after hooti attacks of
course as you can imagine this has set
off alarm bells in the west so much so
that many of the NATO countries are
organizing a largescale naval operation
to ensure the security of the area but
how is it possible that a yeni rebel
group is capable of putting one of the
world's major shipping lanes on the
ropes who exactly are the hoodies and
what danger do they pose in this video
we will answer all these questions fire
up your engines and let's get
[Applause]
[Music]
started we've talked about it in several
videos the Arab Spring emerged with a
lot of expectation but in the end it
wasn't a disaster the crisis of several
authoritarian governments in North
Africa and the Middle East did not
improve things but instead seed huge
chaos in many countries recently here on
visual politic we told you about Libya
well Yemen is another good example you
see when the Arab Spring began to break
out in 2011 the hoodies a group based in
Northern Yemen saw their big opportunity
at that time the then hoodi leader Abdul
Malik Al hoodi declared his group's
support for the demonstrations that had
Rison in the country demanding the
resignation of President Ali abdulah at
the time his men took control of the
northern region of Sada which was to
become the major hoodi stronghold and
although this group participated in the
dialogues that were organized to rebuild
the yeni political system after the
departure of Sally the truth is that in
2014 they took up arms against the
government and so began a long and
bloody civil war between the houthis and
the yeni government which soon showed
signs of enormous weakness it even lost
control of the capital sna very quickly
this forced Saudi Arabia and the United
Arab Emirates to enter fully into the
war a disaster one that we have already
told you about in previous videos
nevertheless in spite of everything the
hoodies resisted we have achieved a
resounding historic defeat against the
forces of aggression today they are
extremely angry and we say to them die
of your anger we say this to the Saudi
regime and its allies the Americans the
British and the
[Music]
and not only did they resist but little
by little Maritime skirmishes began to
take place let's just say that attacking
and hijacking ships has a dual function
on the one hand it can help groups like
The hoodies to get funding on the other
hand this activity is an important
source of propaganda and international
influence in 2018 we were already
encountering security assessments and
alerts like this one Yemen's western
coast Falls along the Red Sea a
strategic Maritime choke point through
which nearly 8% of global trade passes
annually including major hydrocarbon
shipments the houti asymmetric Maritime
Insurgent tactics threaten Security in
the southern Red Sea allowing the houes
and their Iranian backers to challenge
their advisories in the strategically
vital waterway at the beginning of 2021
just before leaving power Donald Trump's
Administration added this group to the
list of terrorist organizations
something that by the way was criticized
by the United Nations because it could
limit Humanity Arian assistance in the
area under hthi control perhaps because
of this request shortly thereafter the
new secretary of state Anthony blinken
reversed the decision but now given
recent events things are back to square
one US considers redesignating houes as
terror group after ship seizure but
visual politic Community let's not go so
fast in order to understand this huge
mess logically the first thing to do is
to know what exactly the hoodies are
where they came from what they are
fighting for whether they a religious
political or jihadist group and what the
ayas have to do with this whole story
well pay close attention because we are
talking about a very very unique
group booties a thorn in riyad's
side let's start by taking a look at
this map as you can see the hoodis
originate from the northern part of
Yemen specifically from the sad region a
region bordering Saudi Arabia since 2011
this faction began to take control not
only of sad but also of contiguous
regions in the south of the country
gradually the hthis extended their
control over much of the country and as
the hoodies are a zi Group which is a
branch of shiism the confrontation with
Saudi Arabia was
set Riyad understood perfectly well that
the victory of the hoodies would have
meant that Yemen would become part of
Iran's circle of control and you only
have to look at a map of the region to
understand why this was a danger if Iran
were to control Yemen it would not only
basically surround Saudi Arabia but
would also control one of the most
important trade Crossings in the world
the bab al-mandab Strait the entrance
and exit to the Red Sea and thus a
necessary passage for trade routes
through the sewers
Canal I'm sure that in recent years you
have heard a lot about the military
deployments that the United States
France Japan and China have made in the
small country of Djibouti an
unprecedented concentration of Naval
positions well I'm certain that now you
understand perfectly the reason behind
this kind of stubbornness towards jouti
but that is not all since 2004 when the
hoodi leader Hussein Badin al- hudi was
killed in combat this group has
undergone a long process of
radicalization today its slogan is as
odd and radical as this God is great
death to America death to Israel curse
to the Jews Victory to Islam something
they claim is metaphorical but I hardly
think they going to convince you the
fact is that in 2014 this group clearly
launched a bid for control of the
country at that point faced with the
danger of Iran taking control of Yemen
through the hands of an increasingly
radicalized group 2015 saw the military
intervention of the Persian Gulf
cooperation
Council in March 2015 Saudi Arabia
Bahrain Kuwait Qatar Jordan UAE Egypt
Morocco Sudan and senagal announced a
military intervention on Yemen with the
aim of supporting the government and
reversing the advances of Hoodie rebels
in the country the campaign was
conducted by land and air marking the
combat debut of Saudi
capabilities nevertheless the
intervention of the gulf Arab states
would deliver a surprise a Fierce and
highly prepared houthi resistance that
no one had counted on Yemen War HTI
missile attack on military parade kills
32 houti say drone attacks targets
several Saudi cities houis have fired Ed
430 missiles 851 drones at Saudi Arabia
since 2015 Iranian support along with
their own knowledge of the terrain and
their counterinsurgency tactics meant
that the hoodies not only succeeded in
reversing the offensive of the yemeni
government and its International allies
but since 2019 they also began to
deliberately attack Saudi oil
installations and positions in the
United Arab Emirates and Bahrain they
even went so far as to employ ballistic
missiles in their offensive actions us
touts new evidence of Iranian Weaponry
in Yemen Afghanistan and so Yemen Civil
War became a particularly lethal War to
give you an idea it is estimated that
almost 400,000 people have already died
as a result of the war in a country with
a population of just over 30 million but
now that we know the H's better it is
time to dive into the Waters of the Red
Sea what exactly is going on in this
area what risks are posed by hthi
control in this major Maritime passage
we have been telling you about is
commercial trans it through the Red Sea
really at risk well stay
[Music]
tuned the rebels and the
Sea flanked by Saudi Arabia Egypt and
Sudan the Red Sea is one of the gateways
to the Suez Canal it is estimated that
about 12% of all World Trade passes
through it and up to a third of the
containers that move around the globe it
is precisely for this reason that the
houthi offensive launched in these
Waters is viewed with such concern the
houthi attacks are taking place
particularly in the bab El mandb
straight which separates the Horn of
Africa from the Arabian Peninsula this
Zone has a length of 115 km or around 70
Mi but in width distances of just 29 km
or 18 Mi can be measured from coast to
coast which as you can imagine leaves
large vessels ripe for the hoodies
taking for now one of the solutions
being adopted by some companies is to
divert their vessels around the Cape of
Good Hope south of South Africa in other
words they are opting to go around the
entire African continent the problem is
that this involves much more time and
much higher costs rerouting via the Cape
of Good Hope will prolong transit times
by 7 to 10 days but that depends on
where the vessel is when the rerouting
decision has been made depending on the
vessel's location some may experience an
even longer delay of 2 to 4 weeks if
they've had to detour from the Red Sea
rerouting via Africa would add 7 days to
South Asia us sailings and 10 days to
Asia Europe sailings going via the Cape
of Good Hope and estimates suggest the
extra Transit and fuel costs will be
north of $2 million per vessel and
naturally we're talking about a lot of
ships to give you an idea every day an
average of 50 ships cross the sewers
Canal that's 1,500 ships every month so
we are talking about a potential
multi-billion dollar cost of millions
and even billions every month to top it
off the hthi operations in the Red Sea
are showing a new level of technical
capabilities far beyond what was
initially
conducted we're talking about the fact
that on top of the previous ballistic
missile manipulation capabilities
already known we now add highly complex
tactical actions such as the boarding of
a ship from a helicopter or the
management and tracking of commercial
vessels in the open sea in fact
according to estimates by the Washington
Institute for near East policy the
hoodies like have at their fingertips
Limpet mines torpedo launchers
high-speed boats armed with short-range
rockets and even anti-ship cruise
missiles in addition to ground and air
operational capabilities but take note
because in theory the situation may not
only be a problem for global trade but
above all a tragedy for the Region's
growth estimates why well because the
Red Sea was generating great
expectations for the countries in the
area particularly of course for Saudi
Arabia have you heard of neom well
there's that the Red Sea is positioned
between two continents bordering six
countries in Africa and four in the
Middle East and approximately 10% of all
global trade passes through its Waters
by 2050 Red Sea GDP is projected to more
than triple increasing from $1.8
trillion to 6.1 trillion and trade is
expected to grow more than five times
from $881 billion to $4.7 trillion
however as long as the hoodies are in
control all those grand expectations may
come to nothing and all this visual
politic Community is what explains why
Western countries and particularly the
United States are taking matters into
their own hands the problem of course as
is always the case is that a broader
intervention could escalate the conflict
particularly one conflict the one that
could pit Iran against the United States
listen
[Music]
up a climb in three
steps
in 2022 the presidential Leadership
Council PLC was created to strengthen
the government of the yemeni Republic
president al-hadi thus delicated his
powers to an eight-member presidential
command Council chaired by Rashad Al
alimi who redoubled his ties with the US
this was yet another of the many goals
scored by Anthony blinkin one of the
most active us secretaries of State in
living memory a true allrounder it was a
fruitful meeting and very positive and
and today we look forward for this
meeting to
also result in positive outcomes and to
enhance us Yemen relations which are
historic and strategic uh at all
levels once again I would like to
welcome uh Mr secretary and his
accompanying delegation and I'm very
delighted to have this meeting the
problem is that this caused the hoodies
and especially Iranian assistance to
multiply their efforts on the ground
something that set the conflict on a new
escalation path the situation in Yemen
fits perfectly into what is known as a
proxy war a conflict sustained by the
never-ending struggle between Saudi
Arabia and Iran of course now things are
getting
worse initially the hoodies were
fighting with Iranian backing against
the yemeni central control up to that
point the conflict was relatively local
Saudi Arabia LED an Arab coalition to
counter the hoodies which led the latter
to turn their weapons not only against
the yemeni authorities but also against
their neighbors and so began the
regional escalation now the hoodies have
targeted Israel and Western countries
Allied to the Hebrew State totally
unacceptable attacks on Merchant vessels
by the htis in Yemen these Reckless
hoodie attacks are a serious
International problem and they demand a
firm International response to counter
this threat the US has announced the
launch of a joint Naval operation in the
Red Sea called operation Prosperity
Guardian a campaign involving not only
the Persian Gulf Coalition but also
combined Maritime forces from the UK
Italy France and Canada as well as Dutch
and Norwegian logistical assistants in
theory the idea of this International
force is to restore order in the Red Sea
ensuring at all times that it can be
navigated freely for now there are no
details on how the operations to achieve
this objective will be carried out but
it does not take a military genius to
understand that this will basically
require destroying the offensive
capabilities of the houthi forces on the
yemeni coasts and it is here that two
extremely complex paths open
[Music]
up firstly the armed conflict in Yemen
which technically was a battle between
hoodi Rebels and the central government
now turns out to be a complex web of
Arab and non-arab interests with a
confus using religious background and a
lot more risk likewise if the US ends up
defining the hoodies as a terrorist
organization again the fighting would
take another turn as they would lack
institutional recognition to be able to
negotiate an eventual ceasefire secondly
the advance of the Israeli offensive in
Gaza is now a headache for regional
players as the who the offensive in the
Red Sea is a direct retaliation to
Israel's actions on Palestinian
territory this would be the first sign
that the Hamas attacks and Israel's
reaction could end in a bigger headache
in fact many experts point out that
Iran's idea is to activate as many
incident hotspots as possible in order
to overwhelm Saudi and American
strategic capabilities something that
tan would be achieving precisely with
the situation in
Yemen visual politic Community the
situation in Yemen is getting very ugly
the houthis are managing to drag the war
between Israel and Hamas beyond their
borders I hope you now have a better
understanding of the latest US military
action that said the questions are now
over to you what do you think of
operation Prosperity Guardian do you
think the West is right to get involved
in this conflict to what extent will
Iran be able to continue to support H
the operations in Yemen will we see new
hot beds of war in the region leave us
your impressions in the comments and
let's start a debate and now if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe to visual politic if you
haven't already done so thank you so
very much for watching all the best see
you next
time
[Music]